there's no I think we all know
um and and Ben Collins came to us as a
clinical informatics Pharaoh from uh
Philadelphia and after a spectacular
Fellowship here he is now at um uh at
Vanderbilt doing an Ethics Fellowship
creating a completely new pathway for
himself and he is here back by popular
demand to speak with us
um so with that Ben take it away yeah
thanks for the introduction I'll share
my screen here
all right do you see the slides
yes yep okay yes it looks great yeah so
I don't know if everyone here knows me
but uh for anyone who doesn't know me uh
is this new Mitch and I completed a I'm
looking for Maddox fellowship at OHSU
this past summer before moving to uh
Vanderbilt University Medical Center the
department of biomedical informatics in
the center for biomedical ethics and
Society uh studying ethics legal and
social issues of artificial intelligence
and Healthcare so today I'll be talking
about the mistrust of minority patients
in healthcare and how the use of
emerging technology and AI influenced
this For Better or For For Worse
I have no conflicts of interest or
financial disclosures for this talk I
would like to take a moment to thank
Paul Gorman for inviting me to give this
talk and I also want to make note that
some of this work represented in this
talk began while I was at OHSU and while
I don't have time to go through a list
of names a great many people from both
OHSU and from roundabout and elsewhere
were involved at various stages and
giving advice feedback and helping to
take the work forward
I'll begin by providing some background
on the use of Technology within the
domain of healthcare including some
context for why considering the trusted
minority patients is important then I
will discuss three problems related to
trust and the use of technology and
Healthcare including a lack of awareness
of bias low inclusion of minority
populations and insufficient Education
and Training for healthcare
professionals then I will briefly touch
on some work currently being done to
address these issues and provide some
suggestions for taking next steps before
wrapping up a summary of key points and
after that I'm hoping that there will be
still plenty of time left over for
questions and discussion
so progress in technology has long been
part of healthcare but we are at a point
of a paradigm shift involving digital
technology and Healthcare which
fundamentally changes even how we think
about health and illness and will
reshape the relationship between health
care and patients
and Technology does not exist in
isolation there are social pressures
that lead to progress and technology and
there are also effects of technology or
in society as technology influences and
is influenced by Society it cannot be
morally neutral but it is often still
taken to be a neutral moral standing one
of the prototypical examples of showing
how a technological artifact may not
appear neutral is actually
um in the
development and use of bridges and in
the article do artifacts have politics
by Langdon winner in 1980 he wrote on
the design of bridges with low order
overpasses in Long Island New York being
constructed intentionally to physically
divide the location by race and class
from another perspective
philosopher technology done IED
developed the idea of post phenomenology
in which relations between humans and
technological artifacts are examined
focused particularly or in technology as
mediators of human experiences and
practices
this socio-technical perspective is
important to understanding not just
technology within the larger social
context but also within the sphere of
Health Care
the coexistence of Technology alongside
Society has long been apparent within
health care for example the stethoscope
which has been regarded as the primary
tool of the physician developed by Renee
lenick was made in part because of his
consideration for uh social etiquette as
he was reportedly embarrassed to place
his ear on the chest of female patients
to listen to their heart
similarly the covid-19 pandemic led to
leaps in the area of Telehealth
while one may believe in the
technological imperative or the idea
that progress is inevitable the adoption
of the electronic health record in the
United States did not take hold widely
until it received the policy and
financial support from the high-tech Act
and the relationship between technology
and Society is not a one-way effect
there's also the effect of technology on
society reflected in health care as well
for example technology has led to the
use of medical testing which has
revealed asymptomatic States as being
aligned with disease or pre-disease
states which has reshaped what is
perceived as being healthy or ill this
sort of medicalization will increase
along with progress in technology such
as with the use of genetic testing and
predictive modeling but with these
emerging Technologies such as predictive
modeling and other forms of artificial
intelligence applications in healthcare
it is not yet clear what the social
effect will be that question remains
open and it is very much dependent on
how those Technologies are developed and
used
quoting a science fiction writer Arthur
C Clarke who wrote any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
or indistinguishable from Magic you may
recognize the background image here as
being from the Disney cartoon Sorcerer's
Apprentice where Mickey Mouse is The
Apprentice of the sorcerer Yin Sid and
going away against it leaves Mickey in
charge and he is tasked with moving
pills of water wanting to find a
shortcut Mickey uses magic essentially
to program brooms to move the water in
his place before falling asleep
and certainly uh Mickey wakes up now
drowning in water the brooms have gone
too far with the water but they were
just following the instructions of
Mickey they didn't do anything against
their instructions and yet now Mickey
has a big problem on his hands
in his book uh the alignment problem
Brian Christian points out how this is
comparative to the way things can go
wrong with artificial intelligence and
digital algorithms
computers only do what we tell them to
do artificial intelligence is a branch
of computer science using digital
algorithms to make complex decisions
with algorithms being a set of
step-by-step instructions for computers
to perform tasks
there are intended benefits in
healthcare one of the largest being
efficiency which is also the same type
of benefit that Mickey was aiming to
accomplish
but there are also a lot of potential
and intended consequences and harms
these harms are generally not computer
error but human error
and unfortunately we have a long history
of poor judgment and bias as humans
in the example of The Sorcerer's
Apprentice presumably Mickey has learned
his lesson and no one is hurt however
that is not how things can happen in
real life especially in healthcare
shifting gears before moving on let's
take a moment to talk about trust
trust can be defined as the general
expectation that the words promise or
statement of another individual or group
can be relied on with an underlying
belief that an entity will help reach a
desired outcome under difficult or
uncertain circumstances
press is typically that of occurring
between persons
and often consider it in the context of
healthcare but it's going to be extended
to include trust between humans and
groups or organizations as well as
between humans and systems or machines
there are many factors which influence
trust but this presentation focuses most
on the influence of minority status the
distinction of majority and minority
status is often perceived as a
distinction of power in many cases the
minority population has less power than
the majority population making it
incumbent upon the majority population
to not use that power unfairly against
the minority population but historically
this has not worked out well for many
minority populations
in part because of historical injustices
and ongoing problems
characteristics which may identify a
population as being of a minority group
are often associated with a decreased
level of trust
in this framing it is important to
acknowledge that mistrust is not being
aligned is a negative it is really a
normal response to not develop trust or
to lose trust under such conditions
there are numerous minority groups which
have had their General levels of trust
decreased when this presentation now
focus on sex gender race ethnicity and
lgbtqi plus minority groups these are
not simply factors of trust is they have
strong effects on how well trust is
built and maintained
but why is trust important to consider
in health care
and Healthcare patients who exhibit
lower levels of trust tend to utilize
Health Care poorly including both over
and under utilization of care and they
have worse outcomes in addition the
quality of patient experiences are
shaped by their trust
minority patients tend to have lower
trust in health care
contributing to health disparities this
trust has historically been uh one
between humans uh the patient and the
clinician and between a human the
patient and Healthcare organizations or
the larger Healthcare System that
Dynamic is changing the increasing use
of technology and digital tools by
patients directly and by clinicians or
the healthcare system and work related
to Patient Care means that this concept
of health health care trust is extending
to trust in technology and like with
Healthcare minority populations tend to
have lower trust in technology
any discussion of artificial
intelligence and trust is incomplete
without some discussion of the concepts
of transparency and explainability in
short transparency is about being able
to see what is being done and why well
explainability is about how it is being
done these concepts are often used to
suggest that AI must be transparent and
explainable to be trustworthy consider
the comparison to how
mechanical device functions such as a
car most people can then explain how a
car works but still
um trusted to do what it is supposed to
do
furthermore knowing how cars are made
how they operate and how they are used
as well as knowing about traffic laws
and transportation policy does not
really help anyone understand how cars
affect life
similarly disclosing the code of
artificial intelligence does not
necessarily reveal how AI Works
especially in the context of society and
we'll do little to understand the impact
of AI or Healthcare and health decisions
both from the perspective of clinician
users and patients
in other words AI explainability at
least how it has often been
conceptualized is not in itself the
source of mistrust
then what is the source of mistrusting
technology for healthcare especially
among minority populations
the answer to that is likely the
perceived risk of harm
and for minority populations this is
largely attributed to bias this leads us
into the first problem related to
mistrusted minority populations in
emerging technology and AI for
healthcare the lack of awareness of bias
in those Technologies
the awareness of bias and Technology
gains even more importance because
computers and digital information are
very easy to disseminate creating the
potential for biases to have widespread
impact and as Friedman and Nissan button
stated uh if the system becomes a
standard in the field the bias becomes
pervasive
a bias is any systematic deviation from
the truth and the processes that lead to
such a deviation there are two names of
forms of bias both of which are
important in the context of healthcare
statistical bias which refers to
distortions of statistical data or
analysis and social bias which refers to
an innate or learned tendency in favor
or against an individual group or belief
Healthcare has a long list of historical
injustices related to biases which I
will not get into much detail on many of
them are widely known and some of them
are less widely known but what is not
well acknowledged is how bias continues
to be a part of the story of healthcare
in 2016 a study showed there remains a
disparity in the assessment of pain
based on patient rates where black
patients were systematically relieved by
medical students and residents to have
less pain than white patients more
recently and actually earlier this week
an article uh showed up in stat news uh
detailing the racist history of a
nephrologist editor for up to date which
many Healthcare professionals look to
for guidance in providing evidence-based
clinical care
and in addition women have continued to
be considered as non-standard in
healthcare and research still
underrepresented in clinical trials and
from that I've been suffering from worse
outcomes of drugs that are marketed
after those trials in particularly
related to higher levels of adverse drug
reactions
there's a similar story of bias when
looking at the use of Technology cameras
provide a clear example of bias in the
form of Technology the focus on
individuals with lighter skin in the
initial development and use of cameras
resulted in poorer quality and
distortions
in the images of persons with darker
skin this became ingrained in systems
and while there have been improvements
in cameras and their use it remains an
issue another common example is the
compass predictive modeling system which
was used to predict the likelihood of
recidivism among those who have been
arrested this predictive model was found
to exhibit biases against black persons
and these are just two of the examples
but the list is far longer
and now we get around to bias in the use
of Technology uh for healthcare where
again there are dozens of examples a
common device for monitoring and heart
rhythm the ultra monitor released in
1960
um although at the time it was known
that women tend to have higher higher
resting heart rates
but there was no evidence to suggest
that women were adequately represented
in the validation of Hotel monitors and
subsequently other differences were
found that were not known at the time
such as in the QT duration measured in
ECGs
yet even by 2002 and through 2007
um women were only one-third of the
participants in clinical trials to
evaluate cardiovascular devices and even
now most consumer wearable Studies have
not reported or examined for sex gender
and skin tone-based differences
in a study that specifically reviewed
wearable devices for these types of
differences it was founded there are
numerous clinically significant
differences
and this Vice goes beyond physical
devices for example documentation in the
EHR has been shown to pull in racial
bias and
um currently working with Sam Lindner
and Ben or Wong
um on a study looking at the use of
Behavioral flags for patient veterans
which has been showing
um that there are other biases and
social contracts
poured in by the electronic health
record
so how did you how do these uh biases
get into these uh Technologies intended
for patients and result in harm as
suggested with another with the example
of the hotel Monitor and uh it is in
part due to a lack of awareness
developers and end users and others
involved in the use of AI systems often
do not foresee the discriminatory
effects of technology and they may not
be sufficiently aware of the problem of
bias or their own biases this isn't just
something that was an issue in 1916 is
now gone like with the examples of bias
and pain assessment and the editor at up
to date these biases are also still very
much present in the development and use
of Health technology today
uh but as we increasingly rely on
technology there's risk those biases
will become less visible
relying too much on technology
interesting technology too much would
then result in an automation bias
has suggested when uh discussing uh
trust with the risk of bias in mind
mistrust of minority populations in the
use of technology for healthcare May
well be warranted but again things are
more complex than they seem
this history of Injustice and bias we
have this guys has led to poor health
care access for many people and
recognizing the lack of Access to Health
Care and the potential for technology
and AI to improve access there are areas
in the world where people of minority
status may have higher levels of trust
in technology for healthcare than the
majority population indeed this was
shown to be the case in the study by
pricewaterhousecoopers
where persons living in lower income
countries
we're much more open to the use of AI
and Robotics for their care than those
living in higher income countries but we
really still don't know enough about
uh how well these systems would work in
those circumstances and what choices
that different populations may make
about the use of AI for their care
for AI systems in the United States
Regulatory Agencies don't require large
sample sizes or breakdowns of study
populations by race or gender
furthermore is suggested by the term
minority there's always proportionately
less data available about minorities
this brings us to the second problem the
insufficient inclusion of minority
populations
to start it isn't always even clear how
we are using different terminology even
in peer review research literature the
terms may be falsely interchange
complicating and confusing the
interpretation of the research and there
are several examples of this
although sex and gender have acquired
political undertones there is an
important distinction between one's
biological sex and social gender that is
essential in healthcare and yet many
studies continue to use the words
interchangeably a similar issue arises
with the use of the terms race and
ethnicity it can be difficult to read a
study and determine exactly what the
study means when these words are used
in the case of
lgbtqi plus populations Claire crunk at
Yale has done excellent work on building
an ontology and recognizing that this
Anthology is in flux
a word used today may not have the same
meaning as it did 50 or even 10 years
ago
so how do we actually deal with all of
this
and I can assure you that the solution
does not include ignoring the problem
in studies on the use of machine
learning in clinical decision support
systems nearly a quarter did not report
sex or gender
and note that even here the
interpretation of the statement is
unclear
there are similar issues with other
minority populations and instead these
studies or
those interpreting the studies will
assume that the findings generalize to a
wider population without actually
looking at those populations
and further even when we are recruiting
minority participants and Reporting this
in a sub-analysis there are often not a
sufficient amount of minority
participants to make strong conclusions
the lack of minority populations is also
a problem from the side of researchers
developers and clinicians the general
I.T felt in the United States is 90
percent white and Asian with other
populations vastly underrepresented and
less than 20 percent of researchers
attending recent major artificial
intelligence conferences are women
and these types of biases can accumulate
for example under representation of
women in imaging data used to train AI
systems under representation of women in
imaging data science and in clinical
Radiology positions could combine to
result in significant negative effects
and some ongoing work reviewing articles
on trust in AI for healthcare has shown
so far that 37 relevant articles
um
sorry in 37 relevant articles only nine
articles report race and or ethnicity
you know just less than 25 percent
and of those articles that did report
race or ethnicity many of them compared
the perspectives of white individuals to
all other non-white individuals groups
together
this falsely assumes that every
non-white group holds the same
perspective this type of analysis could
lead to a significant misinterpretation
of results
if one group holds higher trust and
another group holds lower trust this
could lead to the non-white group as a
whole being seen as having trust equal
to the white participants
designs
decisions in steady design can change
the interpretation of results in
important ways
and while studies will never be perfect
is that so important to be able to
understand what a study means and in the
case of Health technology I also
understand how a technology or AI system
has been trained and what it can or
cannot do
and that brings us to the final problem
the incomplete and porous education of
and training of healthcare professionals
and clinicians on the topic of
technology and artificial intelligence
as well as in diversity and ethics
problem which has begun to attract some
attention but has not been sufficiently
addressed
and it's a quick story so not too long
ago I viewed an online panel about the
use of artificial intelligence in
medicine and I was pleasantly surprised
that the topic of bias was appropriately
addressed which in hindsight I should
have recognized
that would be the case as one of the
speakers was the author of a paper or in
bias in the use of AI systems to
diagnose skin cancer
again
displaying how historical injustices
with camera systems and resulting images
could feed forward to amplify a bias and
create Injustice in healthcare
um however something else stood out in
the comment uh that the panelists made
he expressed uh not being concerned
about the training of clinicians on the
use of AI systems uh pointing out a
comparison between artificial
intelligence and the use of electronic
health records
now I don't believe that this panelist
wasn't informaticist but he is a
clinician
and that stood out to me for a couple of
reasons one is that recognizing bias
tends to require a framework for
thinking about bias which needs to be
learned
but second
EHR systems are poorly used uh in part
because they can be complex but also in
part because they are often not taught
well to users this isn't an indictment
of EHR trainers but more
on the lack of time dedicated to it from
Medical School onward and yet this
clinician who has focused on biased in
the use of artificial intelligence
um did not recognize that deficiency in
the use of ehrs
one of the points of that story is that
there's already so much for clinicians
to learn
medicine is a large complicated and
difficult field
there's always a lot of discussion on
what is most important to know medic and
medical education has always needed to
keep Pace with technological
advancements but these advancements are
coming more rapidly than ever before
and a number of Professional Medical
assists Associated such as AMA have put
forth statements uh supporting the
inclusion of AI and medical education
and teaching the use of AI to clinicians
could help maximize the clinical benefit
as well as avoid the Harms
however
medical education is slow to adapt
and
um
even when change does occur tends to be
very small and incremental
furthermore medical education has always
struggled to keep Pace with the
advancement of technology and there are
currently few physicians in teaching
roles who have experience with the use
of AI systems in healthcare
meanwhile the amount of potentially
relevant medical information already far
exceeds the capacity of the brain yet
medical education continues to focus on
information retention
now I've briefly talked about three
problems pacing healthcare related to
mistrust of minority populations and the
use of technology and AI
now I will give a quick overview of some
work currently being done to address
these problems
first as a study or an exploring trust
in AI for Cancer Care among racial and
ethnic minorities this study is the most
direct study on the topic and will
include focus groups and surveys to
engage with the community on how how
much trust exists for AI systems
intended for Cancer Care across the
spectrum of care and how different
groups might have different concerns
that may need to be addressed in
different ways I'm currently working on
the IRB protocol for this study and
working with a group of other great
researchers including uh Nicole Wilson
Jin McCormick TJ ganta and Victor borzem
and then second
um is a steady or in the development
of an online training module for
clinicians or an algorithmic bias in
healthcare this work uh was used as by
Masters Capstone while at OHSU and will
be fully presented at the upcoming amnia
Symposium but it involved literature
review qualitative assessment uh
programming uh the online module and
then surveys used to receive feedback on
that a link to the module will be
available at the end of the presentation
if anyone is interested in taking a look
then a third study
um evaluating medical students
Investments on the appropriate use of AI
systems in patient care
this work will involve
developing Clinical Simulation scenarios
and randomizing uh students and
residents to a scenario where the AI
system is being used appropriately and a
scenario where it is not being used
appropriately and may provide
incorrect output for the patient
and the intention of the study is to see
how well the students and residents
adapt to the use of the AI system
and
what more can we do about all of these
problems
um
so to start we need to be aware
of the problems and how this and how
people react to those problems such as
bias and taking time to recognize our
biases when conducting research we need
to listen more to people from the
community especially those who may be
disadvantaged by Ai and to recruit
diversely but simply diversely does
little good if we don't use that
diversity to support stratified analyzes
of the outcomes there needs to be more
training on diversity and ethics and the
use of technology and we need Frameworks
to facilitate thinking about issues of
technology and Justice or equity in
healthcare
these framework Frameworks may not be
Solutions but they will serve as a solid
starting point to reach Solutions
there's also a need to intentionally pay
more attention to researchers from
marginalized backgrounds who have
associations with the potential harms of
AI and to recognize their work through
citational Justice
and then we need to also speak up policy
often comes too late on its own often is
a reaction to a problem that has already
taken hold I was actually just in
Washington DC last week to learn about
Federal science technology and education
medicine policy and there is interest in
Congress on the use of artificial
intelligence and concern about bias and
well I'm not here to make a political
statement that concern was represented
on both sides
and advocacy is really another part of
the health professional responsibility
and this brings us to the conclusion uh
to summarize uh trust is clearly an
important issue in health care
with real clinical effects for patients
and this already complicated issue will
be further Complicated by the use of
emerging technology and AI in healthcare
bias has been and will continue to be a
large contributor to the mistrust that
Minority patients may have in health
care
and yet there also remains lack of
awareness of this bias
that lack of awareness is in part
because we don't listen enough to
minority perspectives including minority
patients clinicians and researchers
there isn't enough Education and
Training on these issues
including the use of technology in
healthcare and while we are facing a
critical point in the Paradigm Shift
towards digital Health there is still
plenty that we can do to help minority
patients and to gain their trust from
being aware of the problem to advocating
um
or addressing those problems
and I'll leave you uh last with a quote
from Langdon winner where I added a
little bit to frame and on technology in
healthcare
the important question about technology
becomes what kind of world are we making
this suggests that we pay attention not
only to the making of physical or
digital instruments and processes but
also to the production of psychological
social and political conditions is a
part of any significant technical change
are we going to design and build
circumstances that enlarge possibilities
for growth in human Freedom sociability
intelligence creativity and
self-government or Health Equity and
Justice in healthcare or will we go down
a different path
with that I thank you for your time uh
if interested you can reach the
algorithm bias module via the QR code
code here or the listed website address
and I'm open to any comments
um feedback or questions either now or
through email
so Ben thanks thanks so much for you
know kind of highlighting this really
important topic and
um and making us think about it
um I have one comment and then I know
that Ben santis has a has a comment on
on a question on on chat as well my
comment is this that
um you know bias in healthcare has
existed long before the Advent of
technology or Ai and it has
predominantly been
um has predominantly been fueled by
clinicians
um and of course bias in technology has
existed long before the application of
AI to healthcare
um and that is being fueled
predominantly by programmers and when I
start thinking about this topic what
what strikes me the most is that there
is a societal route to this to this bias
that transcends the environments that we
operate in right I mean the bias exists
as a universal superset of the entire
gamut of activities that we participate
in whether it's in healthcare or
gamitative experiences that we have
whether it's in healthcare or anywhere
else and so to me the biggest question
that I have is can we actually truly
eradicate bias in specific elements of
healthcare I.T like AI without
addressing the elephant in the room
which is the eradication of of bias in
society
how do you how do you square that Circle
Ben what do you think about this
yeah
um it's actually uh
pretty similar to
um
we actually had a
um
Conference of the ethics uh Department
here a couple weeks ago where
I actually made a similar comment
um and
I realized that
um like people in healthcare are
representative of
the larger society from which we come
from there's really no getting around
that
and so
the question is in how do we really
get ourselves to recognize
um the way we think isn't perfect
um and to pursue
uh
improvements and
that really starts with awareness if we
don't believe that what we're doing is
wrong then we'll never do anything about
it
and
so that that's really the the first step
and then
um
it is
true that if Society doesn't change in
how it's reflected in healthcare it
is really not going to change either but
there's absolute perspective that
Healthcare can uh step forward and be a
leader in that change
I think I think if I think you're right
but if no one else does we have to do it
right I mean
um the work needs to be done
um so
um Ben Sanders says thank you Ben really
well done presentation important work
what can you say about current or future
efforts to revise IRB ethical standards
to address these issues of bias and
research design or related to this in
Publications
yeah
um
that is
tough in terms of like
is that there's also the the underlying
question of particularly for artificial
intelligence of where research begins
and ends and where clinical care begins
and ends uh as
um the IRB obviously doesn't have
oversight
over
like the use of these systems for
clinical care when the research is over
um and
yet we clearly need some sort of
oversight over that is AI systems
um can change in their effect over time
so when we're looking at the IRB in
particular
um is there enough
expertise
in the um
make up the IRB groups uh
in general IRB is not there to make a
specific
uh recommendations there's really there
to identify
large
principles and to enforce those
larger principles and it doesn't really
get into the
um the smaller details
so maybe we might need a more
fundamental
change or
something new
to address
artificial intelligence in particular
I think that that's a great point
I preach at that perspective I was just
thinking about
like protected populations right so
there are a number of ways which IRB
currently
carves out and sort of identifies
groups that are at are particularly a
vulnerable to risk
in scientific studies and I'm just
thinking maybe we should be extending
that kind of
uh
you know it's very sort of protection of
specific populations by incorporating
the maybe uh concepts of of you know
anti-bias
um whether or not it's it's
yeah
I I think from a from another
perspective
um there's actually the question of
how much is too much from the IRB side
so and your question is actually quite
timely in that
um
for the uh
um the algorithmic module
study that I mentioned I so I did two
phases of the study when was it OHSU and
when wow or
attempting to to do
uh here in terms of getting uh survey
feedback uh for the module OHSU IRB
approved with no issues medical student
involvement in that
Vanderbilt has not and part of that is
that students are considered uh
protected populations but
how can we learn about protective
populations if we
build a wall
around them and walk around the issues
that they are involved with
um so
like if we're looking at buyers
um
I I really don't have a good answer
for for this but
um are we would we say that like certain
types of studies need to include
some
uh way to deter make sure that they're
not including too much bias or to
measure the amount of bias that they're
including in that study and that I I
don't know
and Ellen says there are other
strategies than irbs to address this um
and also she mentioned that you know
irbs are not competent or empowered to
do
to do this and I know one one thought I
have is you can you can Empower irps to
do this
um but I would be really curious I I
don't want to put Ellen on the spot but
I'd be really curious as to both what
Ben and Ellen thinks are other
strategies
other than irbs
um Ben do you want to respond first
sure I can do that
um
so
um
I think some of it will ultimately
depend on how the FDA responds to uh or
uh the use of AI systems is right now
they only approve static systems that
don't change over time
um
if
they want to start approving uh systems
that change over time then the oversight
from the FDA would likely need to start
earlier
and particularly from the research phase
um then there's also the opportunity for
uh other third-party
um ethics specialist to provide input
well and I'll be a little bit more
radical than
that
um which is that I think the real thing
that we need to be focusing on is how
these tools affect people and to
um you know to understand what some of
their concerns are to get feedback as we
go along I'm not in advocating
necessarily you know community-based
participatory research but I think that
we need I mean this is one of the
reasons why it's very important to have
a diverse array of part of investigators
in the room and a diverse array of
participants
um but I think irbs have a very rigid
approach to how they think about risk as
we're seeing here at Vanderbilt and I'm
I'm not sure that that really helps
um I think if our focus is trying to
develop tools that address that
the the address the concerns of the
people
um who they're going to be used for and
with I think that's the better way to do
it I just don't don't think our irbs
have actually been told they can't look
at their own stream social effects
um and they really can't evaluate the
strength of scientific protocols so we
need to we need to do something
different
um that's what I would say
and then it's interesting you say this
because the very reason irbs were
created was because as a society as a as
a species we've I think proven that we
are we are incapable of conducting
unsupervised research without harming
people
um I I mean to me what you're saying
suggests that that the irbs have become
too rigid and institution could
elasticizing the role of what an IRB or
rethinking what the role of an IRB is
for the 21st century
um be one way to address this I mean the
irbs were a result of a 20th century
commitment to cleaning up research right
so should we rethink that idea of what
cleaning up research means oh without a
doubt and you know and one of the things
about irbs is that they act in service
of the institution not in the Institute
not in the service of research
participants I mean they've been utterly
captured and so I think there is a lot I
I just talked with the head of the
National Academy of Science over the
weekend and I know that there is a
general feeling that irbs aren't doing
their job and they're not
um they are both getting in the way and
they're getting in the way of research
at the same time not you know not
ensuring that all the relevant interests
are taken in state so I think I you know
I think we will see a move in the next
10 20 years to re-examining what the
role of irbs
um uh is because I think they don't work
well
that's kind of a downer but I think on
the other hand I think this kind of work
that says
that is focused on what this research
means for people and what it's going to
take to deliver tools that clinicians
and
can use in ways that patients accept is
going to require a different way of
thinking about it than sort of the
um then the strategies we've done of the
past
absolutely and and Steve said Stanford
has experimented with the variation on
the IRB model that's designed to think
beyond the study and look at Downstream
effect and that's that's an interesting
link and Steve also said that you know
to think about biases to generic framing
it more about risk and harms makes it
easier to think
um about what kind of bias is relevant
and what the best way to think about
that in the context of a specific study
and that's a really good point uh one
one thing I do want to focus on Ben is
the two themes I got out of your
presentation uh one of course is that of
bias the second is that of trust
um and to me
um
you know mistrust in certain sections of
our society is based on history and
um and you could actually argue that
mistrust in in in in some populations is
entirely Justified and and so once you
know a patient engages with uh you know
a clinician and learns over time to to
develop trust then certainly you know
trust in AI becomes the next level kind
of reach goal but we are struggling in a
society where even where folks are are
mistrustful even of Engagement
um and so how do we you know how do we
then think about you know trust of of
of AI and AI related
technological features of healthcare
delivery when even fundamental elements
of trust such as you know engaging with
the healthcare system are in Jeopardy
yeah yeah that's a good question
um
I think like when we've historically
attributed
uh trust and mistrust uh to
um history itself like we've tended to
lean on specific events like the
Tuskegee studies
um and saying like oh these events are
why there's mistrust and that's
partially true but it's much more than
that it's an ongoing continuing
experience
um I think
um there's a lot in terms of like being
able to communicate well with each other
and understanding different cultures I
um understand it
um so there's the ongoing NIH uh work on
a
um AI through the aim ahead program and
they have had uh
difficulty with
um
working with uh Native American
population
due to uh really
um understanding
um
different cultures and
um is they learn
from that they can apply that
more broadly but
that also leads to impasses where like
once you get to a block it can be
difficult to overcome that and a lot of
those blocks are very early
in life as well as in the care process
people learn early on that the
healthcare system is not for them
or
um and
the way that they interact with the
Healthcare System
tends to reinforce that particularly the
inability to get health care and it may
not be until we have some sort of
Universal Health Care system at least in
the United States that we can really do
that it's like it's people are the
pay massive amounts of money or they
can't get the care that they need then
they're never going to trust the system
any other questions for Ben or comments
and if not I want to thank Ben so much
for
um for this presentation and I think
making us think about this really
interesting and important topic
um and Ben you know welcome back and
come back anytime and talk to us some
more we'll always be happy to learn from
you okay all right thank you
thanks